à d'avron les stars du jour sont ces
bouteilles le millésime 2010 9 du
domaine la bouche bureau a été présenté
ce mercredi 9 septembre dans les vignes
yvelines oise
ce vin blanc et rouge est issu de la
première plantation de 2010 est de 3 ha
soutenue par le conseil départemental
des yvelines le premier millésime et il
a une couleur particulière puisque c'est
celui qui qui arrive après trois ans de
travail puisqu'on la vigne mais trois
ans à produire et donc surtout on est
très heureux d'avoir vu dans les cuves
se révéler vraiment le goût du terroir
et faire ses vins qui vont avoir le goût
du lieu où ils sont produits
c'était très excitant puisqu'on a suivi
ses cuves on a planté ses cépages en
fonction du terroir qui ici la
dégustation organisées ce jour-là permis
de tester le niveau de ses premières
vendanges qui se sont déroulés sur le
site l'illinois du 22 septembre au 7
octobre 2019 le millésime 2010 9 s'est
très très bien passé on a une très belle
maturité et surtout on présente pour la
première fois la typicité la singularité
de ces cépages sur ce terroir qui n'a
pas vu devine depuis très longtemps et
qui permet d'avoir déjà un singulier
équilibré avec une grande cure
aromatiques ces bouteilles de vin sont
vendus via le site de la bouche du roy
lé seront également distribués aux
partenaires locaux des alentours
en parallèle le domaine propose toujours
des visites de ses vignes au grand
public jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre